[Musik]
alex ich würde jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt mit uns auf wir haben jetzt
halt doch einfach mal nicht nur dann
geht es mir nicht gut was hast du
mir geht's gut sollte auf jeden fall
habe ich heute hayek und sollte auf
jeden fall habe ich heute heilfroh man
dabei wir haben vor zwei drei monaten
zum video gedreht obwohl das schon
länger her oder
da haben wir songs erwarten das video
ist echt richtig gut angekommen fiel am
beschrieben er macht dann noch einen
part und deswegen haben wir uns heute
hier versammelt gemeinsam um noch
dreimal dürft ihr raten richtig in fahrt
zu bringen
auf jeden fall wollen wir gar nicht
lange da waren wir starten direkt in den
zweiten part wir haben gerade schon ein
paar gedreht also theoretisch ist sogar
der dritte partner oder ist das jetzt
mal ganz genau in dem hinter der kamera
haben wir den gefürchteten
schiedsrichter marc gené
also es werden ist vielleicht zwölf
songs abgespielt von mag wer davon die
meisten erregt hat gewonnen wer die
wenigsten reden hat verloren klingt am
ende eine dicke bestrafung wie viele
draußen im schnee statt es hat hier
nämlich geschneit ganz wichtig man muss
immer quatschen wir haben schnellsten
klatsch ist dran
fünf sekunden zeit den songs zu erraten
oder sagen wir drei jetzt machen wir
drei gesagt letztere sind so 2018
ok auf die plätze fertig jetzt geht es
wirklich los mag bitte sag uns was du
kannst spears toxic ja wieder sieg an
den weiteren nächste bitte es ist es
nicht das ist ein anderer das ist nicht
klar wo man das schon mal raus weiter
weiter weist kritik
[Musik]
man ist also für mich jetzt schon was
nicht weiß was genau so wie kannst du
hast ja ich hatte jetzt gesagt ach das
ist es gar nicht telefoniert
ich weiß nicht was ich weiß musik hören
wir den rund zwei wochen sprang dabei
ein paar die news miley cyrus weil dies
alles danke das fehlt ja doch das ist
unfassbar
wir haben sie eigentlich so gemacht dass
man nur titel sagen muss ich hätte ich
mal nicht geklappt hätte ich das safety
car ist mir bereist wieder beweist dass
auf jeden fall billiger ist ja geil
jetzt auch welche aus so gemacht also
nicht mal sagen
[Musik]
ich bin viel video beweist euch alle ich
dir dass du fährst oder wer war zuerst
ich würde sagen wir gehen einfach weiter
in die nächste runde
wir haben bei den super zuerst wo man
also es war erzieherin mit ich hab auf
jugend warum nimmt man denn so etwas
einfach ist das ist ja richtig einfach
oder
ja ich kann es kommen wahrscheinlich ja
[Applaus]
das roma gehalten bei oder palästina
heißt kraft also leute kurz dazwischen
standen wo man hat leider drei ich habe
leider 0 und reich hat leider einen aber
er ist auch nicht weit entfernt von mir
[Musik]
die gummibären gucken sich überzeugt
dass ein oder falsch ob das ist ja das
sind die kuh warum gerade jetzt gesagt
dass er sich heiser und das ist nichts
weiter als habt ihr alles kann und ich
auch noch ja okay was was ist so richtig
was war das denn auch gummibärchen
gewesen waren
sydney meinte werden waren oder ja kommt
für mich
[Musik]
er hat uns gerade den zeugen vorgesehen
als gesagt dass anhaltspunkte was macht
alex das land muss was sagen die
forscher keiner punkten keiner hat was
ich jetzt okay kein abo 3 1 3 0 1 und
ich weiß
oder es kann natürlich das originale
seien ja es muss ein auf
nichts für ungut denn ich habe ja noch
gar keinen punkt
32 wir sind auf deinem kanal um dieses
bild zu stellen
ich will ja nicht stören alle besser wir
zerstören alex wie den von euch gehört
die supreme court no wenn dir dein ernst
was wollt ihr denn her was welches das
ist mein den gibt's auch immer gehalten
aber das ist ja das ist ja heimrecht
alex wie nachdenken was das normale muss
markus am besten den wir heute es über
sich ok also dass wir jetzt unangenehm
habt ihr wundervoller ja ach was der hat
die usa schon 25 millionen klicks ersten
punkt ach so ja entspannt ich weiß noch
nicht mal ein feature machen irgendwie
zusammen alle so nein hat er nicht
interesse daran
ich könnte auch meine raps gilt somit
eindringen von irgendwie so ein
trauriges
ich dachte irgendwas
kennen sie die causa view davon fast pk
sorge
das hätte ich auch direkt sagen können
so leute ich bin jetzt an schneiden hier
war irgendwie die videoaufnahme zu ende
also ich habe das richtige lied gesagt
aber das ist halt leider nicht drauf
also der punkt ging an mich es war let
go von diesem film also im refrain hab
ich sage checkt vorhalten nicht
erwarteten start stopp jetzt jetzt hört
auch einfach direkt zu klatschen wenn
die leistung nicht infrage komme zwar
spricht und ich halte da kannst du noch
nicht einmal gewusst dass du das jetzt
schon vor dem schlager jetzt ist die
zeit abgelaufen und weil er ganz kurz
traurig solche antwort wenn die beide
reden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich kenne dich hab ich hab' ich habe
dich einloggen
aber ich habe auch noch mal keller raus
gehört sein team aktiver schulen sind
ein bisschen gehalten sind
es hat eine vermutung
[Musik]
don't track das ist vorher so high
school musical star als turniersieg im
camp rock folge im plus
noch nie gehört
es geht aber ich kann ab jetzt oder nie
gehört was ist von muss in beantworten
aber ich habe ich nicht gesagt
aber ich habe aber ich habe es so noch
nie gehört kennt ihr das unsere
englische lieder mitsingt und sich so
bei der hälfte der wörter nicht so
sicher genau 13 23 wie viel gibt es da
ja es hat das alles passieren
das wird ein
back to bed boy also hier das jetzt nein
du hast mir gesagt komm sag ich ja weg
der welt nichts nein ein bisschen cool
an nein falsch intel core i went back to
bed boy haben geklatscht punkte mit ja
oder nein kommt das was alle machen mit
das machen ist haben jetzt hinterlasse
stunden die ganze zeit so lag
entscheiden also jetzt mal gesagt wenn
ich das auch
333 s haben wir noch einen noch das
heißt wenn theoretisch wenn ich jetzt
den punkt in meinem video wurde dafür
euch weiterhin schlecht wie gerade oder
wollte jeder drei punkte jetzt kommt es
darauf an 1 1 haben wir noch gut von
alles mit um ein gotteshaus
aber die leute wie sie jetzt nach
draußen gegangen sind im tiefschnee
also ist ja wirklich viel schnee
gefallen hier oder passiv auf jeden fall
gibt es jetzt für mich die bestrafung
man sieht auch gar nicht mehr eigentlich
schon gerade bestrafen
also schon sagen 20 sekunden ab jetzt
auf die plätze fertig los
könnte das war so einem video sich auf
jeden fall in zeiten und ich glaube wir
kommen uns jetzt auch ein paar jahren
verdienen